was hat der Nokia getan Nokia versucht
Geld zu verdienen oder wie ist denn
Nokia nach Bochum gekommen hat
der Nokia Vorstand gedacht und
hat gesagt was ist denn die
schönste Stadt auf der Welt
[Applaus]
wo müssen wir unbedingt mein Werk bauen
nein wir haben nur hier gezwungen nach Bochum
zu kommen mit einem Scheck mit 70 Millionen
Euro Bestechungsgelder auf Deutsch Subventionen
70 Millionen hingelegt dafür ist nokiana Bochum
gekommen das Geld war aufgebraucht vor zwei Jahren
und hat Nokia gesagt und hier wird jetzt noch was
damals mehr wir haben nichts das war ja 2008
können sie erinnern da hat man auch Schwung
da haben wir noch kein Geld
genug hier hätte wir das schon
riesige gehabt hätte man nur hier helfen können
[Applaus]
aber so so hat nur gesagt gut da gehen wir noch
Rumänien die bieten 20 Millionen Euro für die
2000 Arbeitsplätze und dann schaffen wir jetzt
erstmal da und dann guck mal wie es weitergeht
und plötzlich als Nokia nach Rumänien gezogen war
da begriff in die westdeutsche zum ersten Mal die
Mauer war unser Freund ja klar wie am besten
auch von der Mauer profitiert wir verdanken
ein Großteil unseres Wohlstandes der Mauer doch
nicht weil wir fleißig waren haben wir so viel
wir haben so viel weil für das was wir bekommen
haben so viel gekauft werden konnte wir waren
ein Hoch Lohn Land mit billigem gehabt die Mauer
hat uns die billigen Arbeitskraft aus Osteuropa
all die Jahre schön vom Hals zu halten und die
billigen epochter die Mauer immer durchgelassen
eine perfekte Membran und wir konnten uns auch
moralisch darüber empören eine Win-Win-Situation
die die Amerikaner bauen wir gerade gesehen
gebaut durch die ganze Wüste hunderte von km
lang mit Stacheldraht schwer bewacht die
Aussicht wünscht sich wie zu Hause fühlen
die Amis versuchen sich die billigen Arbeitskräfte
aus Lateinamerika vom Hals zu halten da geben
die hunderte Millionen von Dollar für aus jedes
Jahr uns haben die mauerkostenfrei dahingestellt
das Ding ist all die Jahre
einwandfrei gemacht worden
und als die Betreibergesellschaft der Mauer
als die DDR 1983 zum ersten Mal einen
wirtschaftliche Schwierigkeiten geriet
da hat Franz Josef Strauß der am Leben gehalten
mit einem Milliardenkredit genau wie jetzt bei
den Griechen wir helfen da gerne aus 1,5
Milliarden D-Mark waren das damals für die
DDR das war eine Riesensumme damals aber da war
große Diskussion überhaupt auch moralisch darf
man so eine Regime überhaupt unterstützen der
Strauß hat gesagt gutes muss erhalten bleiben
aber der Strauß der wusste wie wichtig
die Mauer für das Geschäft machen in
Westdeutschland war der Strauß war
ein Geschäfte Macher der ist doch
nicht als Millionär gestorben weil
der Ministerpräsident von Bayern war
nein der Strauß war der Prototyp das konservative
Geschäfte Machers in Deutschland ja
klar der Strauß hat Geschäfte gemacht
völlig egal der lässt sich doch ein Geschäfte
machen nicht von Wert und Moral behindert
der konservative Geschäfte machen der geht
doch sonntags nicht in die Kirche weil er
an Gott glaubt oder hat gesagt auch
von den sexuell gestörten hören will
[Applaus]
der konservative setzt sich auf die harte
Kirche Morelle hofft Geschäftspartner
kennenzulernen im Umfeld aus demselben Grunde
ist im Karnevalsverein im Schützenverein im
Trachtenverein und in der CDU dann
ist für den alles dasselbe [Applaus]